tous les soirs après l'école c'est la
course pour arriver à l'heure l'Académie
de sport parquet attire les jeunes comme
un aimant elle est le cœur et l'âme du
quartier ouvrier de Buenos Aires dont
elle porte fièrement mais ne vous
laissez pas tromper par son humble
apparence le corridor que les jeunes
traversent pour arriver au gymnase et
comme un temple de la renommée Thérèse
Gago Sorin et tant d'autres n'ont pas
seulement en commun d'avoir atteint les
plus grandes équipes de l'Europe et
remporter des coupes du monde
ils ont tous été découverts ici tout
petit parmi l'autre que Ramon m'a donné
une légende chez les recruteurs du
soccer en Argentine et chaque fois que
Ramon franchit les portes du club c'est
l'extase à coup sûr
parlez-nous de maradonal il demande ce
garçon parce que oui le dieu du soccer
et lui aussi passé par ici dans les
années 90
92 ans Ramon n'a peut-être plus la forme
de l'époque mais il n'a rien perdu de sa
passion et surtout pas son flair
légendaire pour le talent il ne manque
jamais une pratique assis en marche du
terrain concentré toujours à la
recherche du prochain phénomène
elle danse elle tresse regardez les dira
mode la technique le rythme
ici on travaille à jouer des deux pieds
Benjamin Santiago Damian sont d'ailleurs
tous pressentis pour la sélection du
célèbre bocage junior de Buenos Aires
pour lequel ramone a été le scalper en
chef pendant 25 ans et pour lequel le
club parquet demeure aujourd'hui une
véritable pépinière
Santiago à 13 ans il ne tiennent surtout
rien pour acquis des heures de
perfectionnement des matchs tous les
week-ends
lui qui était un distributeur de viande
n'avait jamais imaginé une telle
carrière et c'est une peine d'amour
en fait un divorce douloureux qu'il a
amené à fréquenter le club plutôt que de
sombrer dans une dépression
du club parquet qui lui est dédié décoré
des photos de ses prodiges
y compris Juan Pablo Soline son coup de
coeur de tous les temps
[Musique]
élu aussi un ancien joueur professionnel
devenu gérant du club mythique il dit
que sans ramonnement donné par qui ne
serait jamais ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
école de la pas du FC Barcelone mais il
produit autant de joueurs étoiles sinon
plus
de milieux précaires et bien qu'il soit
fier de son lait
Ramones
des jeunes comme Damian Rodriguez
retenez son nom du titre si il a de la
chance s'il ne se blesse pas
la consécration latin comme dit la
chanson
[Musique]
adapté qui rend hommage aux grands du
soccer argentin et que Damian connaît
par cœur et chante remarquablement bien
entre deux entraînements
[Musique]
j'espère surtout être encore là pour le
voir triompher au sein de l'équipe
nationale
de l'Argentine